the very first recommendation engine
that we built using collaborative
filtering was considered revolutionary
twenty years ago it was an early version
of a machine learning algorithm that
recommendation engine helps customers
discover related items like a camera bag
or the lens for a camera that a customer
had just purchased it's still on the
site and it's still a huge help for
customers when we later combine
collaborative filtering with heuristics
to make recommendations we were able to
give customers personalized
recommendations rather than just showing
them popular items fast forward a few
years add in the exponential growth of
computing power provided by Amazon Web
Services plus the improvement of
sophisticated machine learning
algorithms and we start to get
dramatically better results on the order
of two times better than a typical
algorithmic improvement that's a once in
a decade leap that helps us to
personalize our content and recommend
goods that a customer would like to buy
and movies that a customer's more likely
to watch let me explain how we achieved
these goals and it wasn't a straight
line to realize the improvements in 2012
we wanted to update our product
recommendation algorithm to improve
personalization for customers we started
from state-of-the-art graph clustering
techniques then we shifted our approach
under the hypothesis that deep learning
methods would outperform matrix
completion methods because we could take
advantage of nonlinearities but we found
this approach performed worse then not
only our best collaborative filtering
algorithm but just a simple best seller
a ranked list then we used a common
artificial neural network called the
sparse auto encoder but it was still not
as effective as collaborative filtering
or the bestseller list in fact we tried
methods based on singular value
decomposition by linear regression and
restricted Boltzmann machines nope none
of these matrix space matrix completion
based methods underperformed or over
performed compared to our production
algorithms and simple lists we were
surprised that the state-of-the-art
methods would
perform worse than a simple bestseller
list so it prompted us to take a step
back and think about the objective
function that we were trying to solve we
looked inside the black box to identify
what was happening I'm gonna explain
this in the context of prime video but
the same approach applies to many
products on Amazon
we found that matrix completion methods
learned that classic or oscar-winning
movies would be of interest to many
customers makes sense however we saw
that given an evening at home on a rainy
Saturday customers prefer to watch a
newly released movie rather than an old
movie in other words Captain Marvel
beats Casablanca this learning became
the foundation of our winning approach
we developed a new model for
recommendations using multi-layer neural
networks for classification with trained
the model using a loss function for
predicting what customers wanted to
watch in the next week what you see on
the screen is the formulation behind the
model we took historical movies that
custom that customers were watching in
order to predict the movie a customer
wanted to watch next week the neural
network classifier outperformed other
neural network based approaches that are
much more complicated the simplicity of
this model made it inherently more
scalable so we could expand in many
millions of products and hundreds of
categories across Amazon and it
performed two times better than
collaborative filtering so we had a
winner